what are the strengths and weaknesses of
Joe Biden he is
um not the same Joe Biden that debated
Paul Ryan in 2012 and ran circles around
him in just an incredible debate
performance
uh he is not
inspiring in the way that someone like a
Barack Obama was to people coming up and
starting to get interested in politics I
think a lot of those are fair criticisms
I think on policy he's not interested in
a lot of the things that younger voters
are interested in I mentioned cannabis
reform I mentioned student loans so so I
think that that's a deficit for Biden I
think the upside to Biden is when it
comes to foreign policy diplomacy
high-level negotiations knowing how to
engage with allies in a productive way
it's tough to find someone with more
experience than Biden